I hope these questions were gonna be
dirtier the next one is what color is a
we're playing never have I ever
I haven't played this game since like
colors I don't think I've ever played
this game before we'll take a risk is
what we're doing never have I ever cried
during the kids movie uh duh Finding
Nemo oh you'd never cry no no oh my god
a kids movie did you the Toy Story 3 um
yeah I have over there yeah for
Charlotte's Web babe Little Mermaid Oh
also Lion King all right see now if you
what you would have said like he gave it
to you never have I ever flirted my way
out of the ticket nobody explain
yourself
what were you speeding I did get it up
and I think the officer was like this
poor sweet little giggle never have I
ever been caught social media stalking
is that like lurking stalking like the
word of stalking
I have it cuz talking I mean I'm not a
stock you know it's a pin line oh my god
I recently got caught I'm nosey I'm very
nosey of course I'm gonna check up on
you I'll say it
yeah I've looked at your page Amy and I
had not been flicka's never have I ever
done to walk of shame
Wow Oh dad I already know how does done
booth shake am I have not because when I
was a pro no I'm proud of it yeah well
done yours is earthling can you move me
oh never have I ever stooped to a
friend's bathroom or bedroom Oh duh all
the time I want to know what's in there
I totally have I looked through yours
you look tonight no I feel like I
learned a lot about [ __ ] I mean I
didn't know that she likes to snoop
through people's bathrooms first of all
I learned that he cried during tourist
Toy Story 3 to me 3 oh my god the Lion
King I went on my the island my life I
was living my true thank you
I respect that about you your talk do
you think that about you
yeah that's right hi oh no dignity